[Musica]
qual è
il vostro super eroe o la vostra
superoina preferita
alzate la mano chi fa parte del team
batman
o ti ho pochissimi
poverino
alzi la mano chi fa parte come me se non
avesse capito del team wonder woman
vedo un po di timidezza siete stanchi
orario di aperitivo no no dai su
allora un urlo per il team
superman
scusate regia e infine
la casella altro ovvero tutti i
supereroi le supereroine che non ho
menzionato e come al solito è quel flag
quella casella alla fine di tutto chi fa
parte del team altro
marito superman vero sì superman allora
a parte wonder woman
il mio supereroe preferito e robin
non robin hood che rubava ai ricchi per
sfamare i poveri da marobin di batman e
robin
giovane attivista
spalla fondamentale di batman per
combattere il crimine a gotham city
un ragazzo la cui maschere realtà stata
investita da diversi personaggi anche
una donna a un certo punto è che decide
di una fase della sua storia personale
di spogliarsi dal ruolo di eterno numero
2 e di fondare la teen titans league la
lega dei giovani titani
un po come ho fatto io nel 2012 quando
con alcune amiche dopo tanti anni di
frequentazione di associazioni giovanili
e reti di donne non c'era una rete di
giovani e donne e la rete con gli han
guiman network ce la siamo fatta noi
la storia è piena di robin pensiamo solo
alla letteratura
cosa avrebbe fatto sherlock holmes senza
boston
elementare no
e pensate
quante volte sarebbe morto harry potter
senza hermione dai non avremmo mai fatto
sei libri
la storia della sostenibilità e piena di
supereroi e di super eroine
lei è elena gualinga leader assieme a
sua sorella nina della comunità indigena
dei sarà raku siamo nelle mazzoni
ecuadoregna
nel 96 l'ecuador decide di vendere i
territori dei sarà yaku senza consultare
la comunità nativa li vende a una oil
and gas straniera argentina per
l'esattezza per attività di esplorazione
e di estrazione
che di voi ha un contratto di locazione
o di affitto di un bene immobiliare
gli altri vivete l'illegalità vero ok ok
non lo diciamo giuro che rimane qui
nasce e muore qua
anche se una comunità indigena non ha un
contratto scritto che definisce i suoi
diritti di proprietà e il diritto
internazionale dice che se una
popolazione vive ancestralmente in un
determinato territorio quella terra gli
appartiene
e la comunità può esercitare dei diritti
l'ecuador ha violato anche il cosiddetto
consenso previo libero e informato cosa
significa se io sono uno stato e voglio
destinare un territorio a un progetto di
business
prima di farlo devo consultare la
comunità nativa e senza alcuna forma di
coercizione ma guarda un po devo
convincere la comunità a darmi il suo ok
per la destinazione di business che ho
scelto passo su passo però prima che il
progetto sia messo in piedi la comunità
locale deve conoscere cosa succederà e
soprattutto la cosa fondamentale che
privati di un territorio
la comunità deve avere o un compenso
adeguato corrispettivo o un alloggio
alternativo
lui è il riparto gualinga lo zio di
elena nel 2013 da attivista di amnesty
international ha avuto il grande
privilegio di accompagnarlo in giro per
l'italia per raccontare la storia dei
sarai a cui
ho fatto anche una promessa eriberto
tanti anni fa che ogni occasione sarebbe
stata buona per raccontare la loro
storia
ora vorrei condividere con voi tre
lezioni più appreso da eriberto sperando
possano essere di ispirazione per tutti
lezione numero uno
oltre al tasto di accensione spegnimento
[Musica]
c'è molto di più che si può fare con un
ipad ve lo sareste mai immaginato che la
comunità dei sarà yaku è quella più
digitale del mondo
e pensate che l'ottanta per cento dei
giovani nella comunità sceglie facoltà
che vanno dall informatica le nuove
tecnologie
la prima lezione che mi porto a casa de
riberto e che nonostante io sia un
attivista quindi cerco sempre di
lavorare sui miei unconscious byas
pregiudizi inconsci tutti possono essere
colpite da questi by us e quindi bisogna
sempre lavorarci lavoriamo sui nostri by
us
regola numero due che ho appreso da
riberto
ogni danno ambientale comporta sempre un
impatto di tipo sociale non vale il
contrario
immaginate
l'emissione in atmosfera di agenti
climalteranti
in soldoni inquinamento dell'aria mi
perdonino gli scienziati cui presenti in
sala
ora attenzione che inquinare l'aria
vicino a una comunità
di abitanti una popolazione significa
mettere a rischio il diritto alla salute
di quelle persone siete d'accordo con me
pensate però ha un sistema di economia
locale dove una comunità vive di pesca
agricoltura
se ricordiamo bene forse dalla lezione
delle scuole medie dal liceo
l'emissione in atmosfera di gas
climalteranti
può causare il fenomeno delle piogge
acide e quindi quegli agenti inquinanti
chimici vanno a contaminare magari il
terreno preposto l'agricoltura i ladri
preposti alla pesca quindi
l'inquinamento ambientale può inficiare
il diritto alla salute ma anche il
diritto al lavoro delle persone e magari
se si tratta di una comunità che mangia
a filiera corta
andiamo anche a impattare negativamente
sul loro accesso al cibo
danno ambientale
diritto alla salute diritto al lavoro
accesso al cibo non si tratta di andare
a compromettere il diritto che ogni
persona dovrebbe avere ad avere una vita
dignitosa
e durante le attività di esplorazione
nei territori dei sarà yaku questa
compagnia era un po anche old style
nell'esplorazione sono state inserite
centinaia quintali di mine fatte
esplodere in amazzonia che hanno
sicuramente impattato la biodiversità ma
anche l'economia locale di una
popolazione nativa pensate sono stati
fatti saltare in aria alberi millenari
sacri per i sarà yaku quindi un impatto
sulla diversità è un impatto sul diritto
al lavoro ma in questo caso anche sulla
libertà di vivere la propria cultura e
la propria magari religione
ogni danno ambientale
comporta sempre un impatto di tipo
sociale
regola numero tre
e sarai aqu mi hanno insegnato
l'importanza
della minga non ho detto la famosa
parolaccia siciliana è ho detto minga
significa che ognuno in una comunità
dovrebbe mettere ciò che può dovrebbe
mettere le proprie competenze il tempo
che ha a disposizione a servizio del
bene collettivo e questo che fanno i
sarà yaku eriberto mi ha insegnato a
utilizzare l'ipad perché un regista
videomakers anche pluripremiato in latin
america è praticamente
ha filmato il cammino dei sarà yaku dall
ecuador fino al cile quando la comunità
si rivolta alla corte interamericana dei
diritti umani per chiedere di condannare
l'ecuador
nel 2012 c'è stata una sentenza storica
lo stato dell'ecuador è stato condannato
per aver violato i diritti alla terra
dei sarà yaku e il cosiddetto consenso
libero previo informato sentenza di
miliardi di dollari di risarcimento
dallo stato ai sarà jaco e grazie alle
schede eriberto mette messe al servizio
noi oggi conosciamo la propria storia la
storia della rai a cui è pubblica e
accessibile a tutti ha fatto anche un
bellissimo documentario che si chiama i
discendenti del giaguaro
alberto è una sorta di robin moderno non
è il front woman front man dei sarai
anche quello esposto su tutti i giornali
ma è quella persona fondamentale che fa
il suo pezzo dal suo contributo e mi ha
ricordato anche perché questo modo in
cui vivo nei sarà jato che in effetti in
una comunità di robin ce ne sono
tantissimi perché ognuno nella lotta al
diritto della terra per tutelare sarei
acu ammesso quella sua goccia
fondamentale per far sì che poi
l'ecuador si pronunciasse a loro tutela
penso che conosciate tutti quanti questa
ragazza greta team berga
greta in realtà è accompagnata da
centinaia ormai migliaia e milioni di
ragazzi in tutto il mondo tanti piccoli
robin che insieme creano un impatto
straordinario
un'importante filosofo americano il
professor zimbardo
dice che i supereroi in realtà
sono persone comuni che fanno azioni
semplici che però possono avere un
impatto collettivo straordinario
ebbene non è necessario essere elena
gualinga greta thun berg e fare attività
alla wonder woman o alla batman o la
spider man di turno ognuno di noi con il
proprio tempo libero con le proprie
passioni può fare dei piccoli grandi
gesti che però possono come una goccia
nel mare a portare un grandissimo
cambiamento collettivo
tutti ci vorrebbero dei fenomeni
io non sono sicura che nessuno vuole
essere robin ma io credo che in un mondo
attuale pieno di sfide dove questa
maglietta non è soltanto un cotone
biologico ma racconta la storia delle
persone ognuno di noi abbia il dovere
morale
di essere ciò che vuole nella vita ma
deve avere il coraggio anche
di essere robin
siate robin
[Applauso]